so i think anish needs to strike in this
first game magnus would love just a
solid draw maybe and uh okay we start
it's a queen's pawn opening d4 on move
one how is magnus gonna react he's
surprised us in the opening many times
already in the first two days of the
oslo esports cup and here we go queen's
gambit is he going to accept the gambit
no the gambit has been declined and
we will see just both sides develop
their pieces now magnus taking a small
break there sipping some water and then
i'm pretty sure he's going to bring a
knight out
okay i might if he's in gambling mode
he's also played c5 here
which is a gambit line and uh i expect
to niche as well nietzsche is incredibly
well prepared this one is actually a big
surprise it allows
white to play an extremely aggressive
setup this is the triangle variation i'm
not sure why they call it that no it's
the triangle
but it's uh yeah white can now sacrifice
pawn so this is this is very interesting
already i feel yeah so pushing the
central pawn forward to e4 for white
would lead to a pawn sacrifice
potentially called the martial
martial attack i think and ivanka i was
going to say do you think he's going to
do it he's gone for it well he has gone
for it uh by advancing that pawn in the
center while chaos is about to get
unleashed
and uh
those viewers with eagle eyes can uh
gonna zoom in and tell us what he's
listening to magnus carson that he's
getting his priorities right getting the
music first yeah is this a day to to
have some up speed music on do you think
to to get as much energy as he possibly
can she might need it and here we go we
saw a porn trade a check and black has
indeed captured a pawn in the centre of
the board now we see a bit trade bishop
for night magnus will now take the white
knight in the centre of the board so
black is a pawn up but look at black's
development it's pretty terrible i've
had loads of games in this knight e2 is
a very rare move uh in this position
the old theory was that this actually
leads to a draw um there's a book
written by um peter wells grandmaster of
england uh really good book on the
semi-slav and uh i think the furious
still stands but 92 might be a very
clever choice to to try and trick magnus
here uh potentially who might have been
expecting the bishop to go in front of
the king but
this is i love this position for white
because of that dark square dominance
you get yeah i must admit simon just a
couple of weeks ago i was
at my flat just lying in bed and i
turned on
twitch i went to your stream and i saw
you have uh i think this position but
maybe you blocked with the bishop
instead
and then i saw after black's knight came
out to the edge of the board so the a6
were to attack white bishop you okay it
didn't happen but you played a cool move
there putting the white bishop up next
to the black king and i probably lost a
couple of moves later but we might go
there
but i was enjoying it it still looked
cool yeah
but usually this is a really cool
position for white because you control
all the dark squares look at white star
square bishop and and in fact the main
kind of move as my understanding goes is
actually for the white queen to dive
into the position and plant herself in
the d6 square and it's all about dark
squares i mean black is going to be
facing a vicious attack but you know if
magnus survives then he will be a pawn
up yeah and uh it's not necessarily his
style to get greedy and grab pawns so i
think it's not purely because of the
pawn here it's more because magnus
thinks he's done his homework well and i
guess anish maybe not so experienced in
this line clearly he studied it but not
many people actually allow this nowadays
that's why you were so surprised simon i
mean from the black side it looks so
scary yeah i wouldn't be surprised
they're both gonna struggle to record
their theory i know they got a
tremendous memory but
knight e2 is a bit of a surprise niche
couldn't have expected this opening and
now anisha's playing against this last
move of magnus's which is also not a
normal move so they're trying to get
into i feel a uniqueish position uh both
players um
ivanka's suggestion of moving the cree
the queen straight in
is very typical for this position and
even trying to castle queenside but this
is you know it's a really interesting
gambit line i think you can always uh if
you're not sure of the name of the
gambit line you can always just guess
marshall because there's so many there's
so many martial gambits and he has gone
for your move there ivanka there's the
marshall gambit the royal lopez the
marshall gambit here and named after the
great uh american attacker yeah frank
marshall uh also a famous chess club in
new york the marshall chess club is that
the same marshall yes he's named after
him
so i mean a lot of players have lots of
things named after them yeah um
it's unfair they stole all the names
before we came along
there's nothing left to invent that's
difficult or is there i had a book
actually recently the williams harry
attack so is that free h4
yeah yeah so uh yeah but i don't know if
i can really claim it basman was the
first person to do it so we need to
start the marketing campaign now so yeah
there's also a towel variation but it's
actually not named after david oh it's
another owl actually there's two grand
masters called howell i've never
actually met the other one uh but it's
not named after either of us it's named
after someone else
and there's a williams variation but
it's another williams as well so it's
like come on guys
so
maybe we just need to change our names
to marshall then we're all okay
so yeah you know i'll go frank you can
go bob and bob marshall yeah let's see
what what is like the
the newest uh sort of opening in chess
the freshest that is actually you know
something that is used a lot like the
spanish or i mean just while we've got
him on camera magnus i'm not sure his
eyes are open there but just while we've
got him on camera
there is a carlson variation now against
the sicilian which is relatively new i
think it was only developed a few years
ago
it was actually suggested to magnus and
peter heiner nielsen his his coach it
was suggested to them by i think a fide
master an international master he sent
them all the notes and carlson was the
first one to play it and first one to
kind of bring it to the top level and
now it's super trendy everyone's playing
i mean i think there's something like 1
600 different openings um roughly around
there it used to be like 1 500 and
something so does
that have got different names that is so
something it's a big number um but of
course it's so hard now to play a
different opening because everything's
kind of at the stage being experimented
with at least um
so yeah but there's still i mean chess
is such a fascinating game i wouldn't be
surprised if there's gonna be lots of
interesting things found in certain
positions yeah as you know computers uh
find uh things meanwhile a really
interesting move there from magnus he's
dropped his queen back offering a trade
it looks very very close to checkmate
already white's queen looks like it can
kind of slide up next to the black king
and deliver checkmate but the two black
knights cover any square the white queen
wants to use so no checkmate yet and uh
big question for gary to trade queens or
not to trade queens and conventional
wisdom would tell you not to trade
queens if you're a pawn down gary
remember having sacrificed that pawn so
i'm expecting him to just retreat his
queen maybe down to the dark square to
the d2 square nice and safe avoid any
trades and as simon mentioned white is
actually already
prepared to castle on this queen side on
the left side and black meanwhile still
needs three or four moves to organize
anything like that
so i think that would be
my move my choice yeah i mean i'd love
to have this position against magnus i
mean
you know you play a classical game
against him he's so hard to beat um
you get a position like this is there's
tactics you you know magnus can't castle
easily you've got great tactical
compensation quick development these are
the kind of games where i often see
magnus getting in trouble i mean i think
that's why in previous tours he's he's
lost to uh play other players like his
second the russian player
um help me here um
yes that's right yeah yeah he lost to
him once because he played all this very
exciting uh exciting chess against him
so i think this is uh this is you know
anisha's got something he'd be very
happy with here yeah and i like your
idea just coming back with a queen looks
very very sensible yeah because why not
why not keep the queens on if you can as
mentioned you can't come in here yet
because it's guarded by a knight you
can't use the the other square to
deliver checkmate because it's guarded
by the other black knight and uh if you
can't break through yet why not just
prepare and retreat the queen some of
the ideas
are very long term for example black can
never really castle on this side yet
because the bishop cuts through that you
can't castle through check and uh yeah
for example if black just develops a
knight uh you could just castle on the
queen side and as simon mentioned this
is i mean this looks fantastic for like
you're lining up the queen and rook
already on this open file
you can even drop your bishop back to a
different diagonal at some point and
start kind of switching your focus
and it looks really really scary already
for magnus carson i mean yeah there's a
lot of lines where that bishop goes to
the diagonal you point it out there
anyway
because that's where black's king
generally has to go especially now
there's too many pieces in the way in
the queen side and you've always got
long-term compensation you've got two
bishops anyway um you've got this
minority attack your pawns on the king
side so even if there's nothing
immediate it's long-term uh problems
that magnus has to overcome so uh throw
all the pawns forward yeah yeah why not
because your king's on the other side
typical way too but a very very exciting
position and uh very brave um
of magnus to play this i mean i wonder
what niche is feeding now as well i mean
surely he's happy would you think he's
happy i mean i'm very surprised by
magnus's choice primarily because also
he doesn't look like he's in the best of
uh
health yeah and i traditionally kind of
associate when you're not in the best of
health maybe you just kind of steer the
game into karma waters but no and we see
there anisha's rejected the queen trade
and well they're following the line that
you've suggested and that's going to be
a choice whether you castle the king to
the left or maybe you dive in with the
bishop he's ready to do that it looks
like just looking at anishigiri's screen
now it looks like he's about to click
and castle his king over to that side of
the board as we showed so
i'm just surprised okay there we go and
he does castle his king
but i'm surprised he took three minutes
or so uh just on the previous move
keeping the queens on surely if you know
that you're playing
an opponent who's a bit unwell uh
especially if you're pawn down you
should keep the queens on so he could
have played that move immediately put
pressure on magnus on the clock as well
so yeah we have seen a niche in the past
just one tiny criticism from maybe a
couple of years ago was that he would
trade queens in positions where he
should just go for the attack we saw
that on the tour last season but uh
these days he's more aggressive more
dynamic and he did keep the queens on
but maybe just fighting against his
natural instincts there
i mean still looking great for white i
totally agree um
and there's many plans that white can
play here i'm just trying to work out
what black's going to do i mean
black will have to move that king i'm
wondering where white puts the f pawn uh
because you know when we see this idea
the bishop dropping back i guess does
white push the f pawn
two squares to attack the queen or does
he just push it one square to control um
control black's pieces and then go for
the g pawn support the g pawn both these
plans look look very scary uh um to me
um it's only one pawn after all i mean
it's only one little guy we don't mind
too much about them do if we're going to
get an attack so it's uh yeah i mean i'd
always take white here um
would anyone take i mean you're a pawn
grabber you've anchor i am a porn
grabber but uh i do like my king to be
safe i mean it's a bit uncomfortable um
in this particular position so here
following kind of my ideas of king
safety i would be tempted actually to
pick up the seaport and push it one
square and just shut that bishop out you
know i don't care if my queen gets
kicked about as long as my king gets to
the right side of the board and then i
can breathe a huge sigh of relief that i
haven't i'm not going to lose into any
moves now white's dark square bishop is
the mvp as they say these days the most
uh valuable piece right now uh so it
does need to get kicked away uh so i
advocate for that one as well
mvp or any piece every piece
most valuable piece normally i think
it's never heard of that sporting term
most valuable player yep
it's always like uh
at the end of like world championships
or some sort of the tournaments the uh
they have the mvp
man in the match but then we could also
a man of the match yeah
we could also use vip a very important
piece
yeah we think we should make that jump
after every game we're gonna we're gonna
name the vip yeah the mvp
whatever in the match report yeah
but rsvp won't get you anywhere um yeah
and uh whilst uh magnus is contemplating
how to defend this position i do want to
share with you a selfie from abbey shack
and remember we love receiving selfies
remember take them in landscape mode and
abhishek is doing coding on sunday wow
it life
but uh now but how can i miss chas and
the amazing show yeah you can't you can
multitask these days
code chess impressive device coding that
sounds like uh you know
it's in the same category as chess take
some brain power to do the coding
yeah i uh i did an event a while ago
where i played a simultaneous event
against a bunch of programmers and they
were saying there were so many
similarities lots of problem solving in
jazz
and programming and i don't know too
much about my uh about this stuff myself
i'm terrible with tech but uh that's
what i've heard some similarities they
originally said like uh mathematics or a
lot of people thought that but i don't
know if that's true and then other
people think music
i'm you know i'm not sure really i mean
there's a cool picture there you can see
anisha's glasses exactly what part of
the board he's looking at yeah you can
basically look at chess through the eyes
of an each geary right there literally
yeah through i think this technology
being developed that they can you know a
lot of eye tracking technology which i
think would be amazing for chess
to to see where the eyes are like
zooming in on the top players because i
imagine you know where players like
anish magnus are looking is completely
different
to lower rated players so it'd be very
interesting maybe a very good way to
sort of show where you should be looking
at a position and why um so that that
could be a new you i don't know new idea
for the future yeah some um
yeah i reckon the top players in the
world they'll be scanning the whole
board they might know where the action
is but often lower rated players who are
less experienced they'll just be focused
purely on one part they'll forget what's
happening on the rest of the board yeah
that kind of tunnel vision rather than
full board awareness
yeah i had an interesting thought the
other day which was just like totally
random which was um
okay so magnus has in fact um kicked
away the dark square bishop and it was
um
do you think if your native language if
if the written kind of word is kind of
character based is it easier
to memorize chess script no chess
notation
i've never seen a random character-based
language like chinese it's
character-based okay meanwhile like uh
arabic and and uh
english and the latin based languages
are alphabet based i was just wondering
whether there was like some
i was just wondering for me i'm not i
don't know about
who understands lots of different
languages to answer that question for us
i think
yeah yeah well this
yeah this move is key isn't it so this
is maybe a critical little moment here
isn't it because of what this is black's
idea
yeah yeah and uh i think we have to jump
into the board to show this because some
chaos is about to happen
instead uh of defending his queen just
to rewind one move instead of defending
his queen or running away uh from this
attack magnus has counter-attacked he's
jumped in with his own knight and as you
look at anishi on the camera now he's
just staring straight down he's not even
looking at the screen anymore he's
trying to calculate and he's gone into
his mind palace to do that and this is a
counter-attack hitting the white queen
and hitting the white bishop at the same
time now if the black queen is captured
magnus will simply take the white queen
and yes black is still a pawn up there's
still some stuff to calculate but at
least the attack against the white
bishop means that there's no real time
to grab the black knight the variation
continues for example any could capture
this pawn and maybe with a healthy
position the alternative would be to use
the white queen and capture the black
knight the white queen was going to fall
anyway in that variation so you might as
well give her up for a night and now win
the black queen and it looks like white
is just a piece up white has an extra
bishop but at the very end you see
knight takes pawn and
suddenly there's a fork a double attack
both the white rooks are
under fire here and one of them will
fall so here you have to do a count
white is a bishop up but black has two
pawns and black is about to win a knight
a rook for his knight and uh yeah it's
just a material equation here you just
count okay i'm gonna be two pawns up
maybe in a situation like this one the
black knight will be trapped in the
corner um just as an example and you
have to work things out there so there's
a lot for a niche to calculate right now
i think it's this position i mean this
is very interesting because those two
lines you pointed out david the last
line is clearly the more ambitious line
so so yeah so if anish now plays queen
takes knight i think that shows really
good ambition on his part that he's
actually really trying to take this game
and win this game if he plays the other
line it looks like it's a bit of a cop
out to me um i mean also
if i was white i would not want to have
allowed this move in the first place i
mean maybe castling queen side was a bit
premature maybe he should have played
pawn to f3 it's still okay but the
queens are coming off the board and that
is something i'm sure magnus would be
very happy with so this this you know
just to get the danger a little bit less
to his position um
yeah fully agreed the queens are about
to come off either black is going to
take the queen now or white can give up
the queen before it's captured by taking
this knight but the queens are
definitely going to depart and we'll
keep you updated on the material
imbalance that will arise once the
queens do get traded off so what do we
think that uh anisha is going to play
bearing in mind that it's the first game
of the day
i'm
tested the water's gonna take the queen
i just have a feeling i have a feeling
it's gonna take the queen okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna say he's gonna take the knight
i have to be a bit different
oh yeah
oh come on
come on that was bad
i mean
you mentioned this is maybe a little i
don't know which move was even better
but david you did say that one of his
slight issues was that he tries to get
the queens off he tries to maybe keep
stable positions too much when it might
be better to go for the more unbalanced
position and that's
possibly what's happened here yeah every
player has different instincts right and
that's anish's instinct uh these days he
kind of plays the position more but
sometimes he does go back to kind of
uh back to his character and just uh he
likes to make those trades likes to play
it safe i think that's maybe one of the
things that stopped him kind of uh
becoming the best in the world but uh
it's something that he's actively
working on so we can't fault him too
much and like you say simon it wasn't
clear maybe this is even better than the
other move but it is slightly ambitious
uh slightly less ambitious sorry uh for
white so right now it's level material
completely level the queens have left
the board black's knight is up for grabs
if uh if white wants to take it with his
rook or his king but the white bishop at
the top of the board also under fire so
if you move the white bishop then the
black knight has time to save itself
maybe trading off for the other white
bishop or capturing a pawn on its way
out of the white camp so um yeah it's
level material the computer slightly
prefers white i think that's because
white's dark square bishop if he keeps
it is going to be one of the best pieces
on the board i think if you take this
black knight off now though no real
issues for magnus carson i think the
game would start turning in magnus's
favor if anything there so what is anish
going to do is he's going to move his
dark squad bishop which might involve
another pawn sacrifice
or is he going to just play it safe and
take that black knight off the board and
so they both have these intruders in
their camps the white bishop and the
black knight now if i was playing my
eyes would only be on that piece i would
definitely feel the threat of another
piece being in my camp
are they a big threat but both the
bishop and the knight for these two
players
yes
and you're right kaya normally and if
anything's in your half of the board you
want to kick it out or trade it off or
get rid of it
okay anish his mouse is hovering is that
over his rook right now is he about to
capture that black knight
i said that that was maybe the least
ambitious option again but it does look
like he is focused on taking that black
knight off the problem is if you move
your white bishop out the way then the
black knight can step back up to the
fourth rank and capture a white pawn
maybe that's the downside
uh maybe you can also make an argument
for the black knight going and capturing
white's light squared bishop
so
would you i mean i would have thought
that if anish does just play the simple
move brook takes knight he does which he
has done magnus now has to take the
bishop let's say he plays g3 or
something that he's still going to be
slightly better because his pawn
structure we talked about porn islands
yesterday he's got two porn islands
black's got that pawn right on that
h-file which is on its own um is that a
good one or a bad one it's a bad pawn
because you want to have that like you
know your pawns are like
friends so when you have them together
they can sort of hold hands and look
after each other but that little guy
over there the black pawn right over in
the corner harry no mates he's harry
nightmares that's right yeah he's like
oh they've left me alone
i'm a bit smelly today
and uh you know
yeah we've talked about that before with
chessboards
yeah he definitely does but so there is
that weakness and and also maybe white's
minor pieces like the knight
has some nice roots and and the bishop
seems fine so the only thing is this is
very much a magnus carlsen type of
position so agreed it's hard to imagine
uh anish being able to create too much
here he has to take a time out to defend
the pawn the black knight was
threatening a pawn over there and now it
might be time for magnus to develop the
black bishop before it gets trapped on
that square black's bishop and rook in
the corner those are the problem pieces
yeah and uh they need to join the game
and uh talking about harry no mates i
mean the problem is is that actually
isn't weakness i mean as long as it
doesn't step forward
and it
it's going to take a long time before a
white rook starts looking at that pawn
and eyeballing it so i mean i was
thinking maybe white could you know
throw his knight um
you know toward towards that direction
but i i also agree like going back to
the position i was quite excited about
and then this position well i'm not that
excited anymore i'll be honest but i'm
also thinking magnus is going to be so
much more comfortable here uh because
he's got his position as you said david
and uh before i i think he would have
been like you know he would be defending
some vicious attack but he's managed to
get rid of that attack so that's that's
the thing exactly simon i mean this is
the type of position that magnus okay
even if black is slightly worse i'm not
sure he is but even if black has a
disadvantage this is the type of
position magnus can defend in his sleep
and even if he's feeling unwell this is
not the type of position where we'll see
a massive blunder from magnus or it's
unlikely to be at least but uh in a
position where he's being attacked if
he's feeling under the weather as well
yeah everything against you that's when
it's hard to play chess right when you
feel everything's just going against uh
well yeah everything's not in your favor
so okay he jumps in with his knight
that's
flashy
and what's his idea here the knight
attacks the white one is he gonna move
the bishop next move is that
no he can't do that can he how do you
think oh he's going through another one
oh no please don't let's check out
what's happening on the players faces
okay because we could be about to see a
draw and
there we go anti-climax it's a
three-fold repetition and a draw